welcome back to the gamespot stage here
at e3 2015 ladies and gentlemen I'm
Chris waters and joining me on stage
Matt Burch and mark from Sony Matt you
work for a developer told heavy spectrum
yeah you are that you are basically
heavy spectrum there's a few other folks
on the team but it's a very small team I
think yeah I mean we're really tiny team
but you know everybody is part of it so
a tiny team but your game is making a
big splash here its shadow of the beast
and it is it looks gorgeous man oh thank
you very much I'm yeah I'm really kind
of amazed as my blood thirsty 3 showing
the game and I'm just amazed that people
have heard of it this is it's fantastic
yeah of course you guys did the sort of
reveal trailer at Gamescom a few years
ago and now the game we're playing it
live right here on the PlayStation 4 and
you just picked up plus 1 blood but
before we get into store the mechanics
of combat and exploration here who's
this guy so the main character in shadow
of the beast is a guy called Alberon and
he was uh it was stolen when he was a
baby and the evil Lord who's king of the
domain turned him into this monster and
then later on he sees his father died
and he goes out for revenge he was
stolen away from his family turned into
a monster and now he's out for revenge
when you're I find when you're pursuing
revenge it helps to have like a really a
lot of spikes coming off of your body
seems like he finds those useful yeah
yeah I mean it's everybody seeking
revenge to take spikes with them it's an
it's highly recommended highly
recommended alright so the shadow of the
beast is is about that revenge is about
this bloody combat splattering the
screen what's the kind of sort of feel
of the game the kind of pace of the game
you guys are going for so I mean that
for me there's two aspects to the whole
world i mean i I've you know we talked a
lot about it internally you know in our
team yeah you know Bruce or but
beautiful is what we've been trying to
go for I'm really glad that you didn't
combine that into like bruta full
or have you come on hey wait doesn't
said it I want to I want to trade mark
laughs before anyone else does brusa
phul it's all yours so in this brutal
game I'm not gonna say that well I can't
make any promises what do you uh did you
just do that with all the spikes like
you got some oh you got your basic moves
you got your special moves talk to me a
little bit about our biron's arsenal so
one of the things that I really wanted
to do which I don't really see in games
these days as habits that you can get
through hundreds of enemies really quick
I meaning in the fight here that's
taking of what I've done about two
minutes 35 guys are being dealt with
yeah and that's you know a pretty high
kill ratio I'm pretty high kill per
minute ratio yeah particularly when you
consider he does almost every single
move with his fists you know he's pretty
much a melee kind of guy he is exactly
yeah when you've got spikes for hands it
makes picking up things difficult well
your strength so exactly you're very
good at a few things and killing people
is one of them so um it's kind of a
really an area of focus for us in terms
of making the game really compelling aha
you know we really wanted to make sure
that there was something that was really
accessible you could just press triangle
and get through guys really quickly and
but if you want to do it and get really
good at the game then you've got to
really think about crowd control you've
got to really think about getting guys
at the exact right time can be really
careful with the mechanics using dodge
using stun using all these extra things
that are your disposal to really be able
to maximize the amount of blood that you
get off your enemies and bloods really
important in this game blood is
important not just as a screen dressing
known as effect to sort of go after that
brutal but beautiful style it's a is it
sort of your score tallies that a
resource you use so yeah blood blood is
a resource that you end up using so the
more you you see in the bottom left
corner there's a bar yeah and that
essentially is the amount of blood that
Alberon is absorbed into his body
and all the magic in this world is
powered with blood so once that fills up
each up one of those segments lets you
do a special move or you can use all of
them so do a blood rage which my able
assistant may demonstrate in a moment
he's doing a special but that these that
resource becomes really important for
you to be able to unlock all of the
other moves and that working out the
best way to extract blood from your
enemies so that you can get access to
these things it's really important if
you want to get great scores and get
platinum metals all the way through the
game so hopefully what it means is that
people who just want to go and
experience the beautiful vistas and the
incredibly strange creatures on some of
the levels really like III I worry for
my concept artist sometimes you know
then you can you can just play through
the game and enjoy it but if you want to
get good at this game you're going to
take a lot of skill yeah you do have
that sort of your sort of going for that
spectrum right of a player experience to
allow you to play it in a way that you
can just go on through but if you're if
you're relishing the combat if you're
wanting to get tricky with it if you
wanted to sort of brandish your moves
with some skill there's going to be
rewards yeah yeah exactly and and one of
the things that I this brings me on to
the beautiful part of that equation you
know hopefully you know the landscapes
look really interesting and really alien
to people and what we want to do is make
sure that while you spend time learning
how all of these combat mechanics work
and how you integrate them and how you
get a great result out of them that
you're going to see the world and see
things in the world that make you think
about it more you play it you see you
know why these statues here how did the
activation work I mean obviously I've
mentioned blood does it activates magic
in this world and aren't killing that
guy in putting him on the altar
activates the temple but then why is
that temple there why do the thing the
platforms move inside it what's
happening there that's stuff I there are
clues all the way through the world but
I don't want to tell players what they
are so they can connect it themselves
while they're learning to the world
stays interesting while you're
learning the combox yeah there's kind of
a line you gotta walk there right cuz
you want to you want there to be some
mystery and you also want it to look
really cool so but you don't want it to
just be window dressing for the sake of
window dressing I mean they're big bones
in the background it's not just goods
like yeah let's throw some bones back
there yeah sort of a lore behind this a
big store like the whole world is
flushed out yeah and so then the
question becomes how you surface that to
the player it seems like you're taking a
little bit of a delicate approach a
little mysterious approach I mean I hope
so I'd really like is for because
because this is based on the game that I
played 25 years ago ah and when all the
fanfiction you've been writing [ __ ] more
or less yeah this is a really kind of
magical moment with the original game
where I went around to a friend's house
and we played it and then you know I was
on my on the bus on the way home and I
all I could do was think about the game
and think about well why was why were
the rocket thrusters underground why why
was that skeletons embedded in the
ground how did it get there it's got
wings how did it get underground that
doesn't make any sense and I invented
all these stories about why that
happened why this was why this made
sense and you know I want to make sure
that with this one that we know exactly
why everything's there but I don't want
to expose it all to the players so that
they can have that same experience I had
when I played the original you know I'd
really like modern players to have the
chance to just experience it and have
that same question of why isn't it 100
in a game yeah captures your imagination
like that and you start thinking about
that world as you know thinking
immersing yourself into it and trying to
really imagine and you know now you
imagine for a living I know it was it's
kind of surreal making this project at
all to be honest I mean I went and spoke
to sony x steph who are actually based
in sick noses who published the original
game in their in their original offices
and i walked in there and saw
the Beast trophy from the original game
in that lobby and when they asked me you
know hey you know it's great you've made
just studio what game would you like to
make I just geeked out basically and yes
I like to imagine you had like three
other answers ready to go but then you
saw that statute it was the top of the
list it was more or less like that I had
a bunch of ideas that the team and I put
together and you know while we were
talking about it and they asked me this
question i just went well shadow the
Beast is awesome and they said okay and
I said more or less I just let my 16
year old self ramble for a bit I know
and they said okay this sounds really
interesting formalize the pitch bring it
back in and then you know we've got the
concept trailer together for gamescom
2013 and we've been working on it ever
since then yeah really that's pretty
incredible story Matt and I'm curious to
know you know aside from obviously
visually you know the changes from 25
years ago what kind of you know what
kind of thing trends in sort of modern
gaming did you sort of want to tap into
bringing bringing back shadow of the
beast you talked about of course being
able to shred through a lot of enemies
very quickly that kind of satisfaction
but you know as sort of a beat'em up
platformer kind of game what what other
sort of experiences you want people to
have as Arbor on well I mean our brawn
for me is a really interesting character
he's not just about killing and fighting
but you know he is a person inside there
he's clever he can do things so worn one
of the briefs that we've got it the
office is that every single level has to
be completely different and we're
looking to do that not just with the
visuals I mean we want to put some
really wild visuals in there you know
some levels of purple some levels are
underground some levels are you know
water-based so hopefully they're all
going to feel really radically different
visually but also each one of them were
trying to get a a game mechanic that
makes it unique and something that asks
you to think about the game slightly
differently to the way that you did on
all the other levels throwing yeah you
know some of them will be puzzle based
some of it will be asking you to use the
platforming in more interesting way
and obviously the combat is a central
theme you know certainly when you're as
you pointed out you know you when you're
equipped for revenge you need something
to deal is done yeah so I that last one
of the things that ends up being kind of
critical because all the creatures that
you encounter are all specific to their
levels as well and they all asks you do
you ask you to do different things so
again I'm rather hoping that it ends up
being this really eclectic experience
that people can just enjoy the journey
but then really discover the depth that
we put in underneath it that's a lovely
word to use and it's sort of I it
inspires me and gives me hope for the
game because eclectic is not necessarily
something you know if someone watches a
quick demo on one stage if they can
their imagination can sort of
extrapolate okay and I'm just going to
continue to be chopping my way through a
bunch of guys but to hear that you sort
of you know committed to that kind of
variety to to making players think and
sort of raising questions and I you know
it's firing that imagination that's
really cool that all that's coming the
original game had that kind of effect on
me and as I say I want to bring that to
modern gamers I remember getting the box
for the original and on the Front's like
this beautiful artwork and then I opened
it up and inside the manual has entirely
different artwork all right I've played
the game and the game had entirely
different artwork again and it had
loading screens in an entirely different
art style and it was just that feeling
of what's going to be next what's gonna
get what am I going to see and each one
of them was like another boom you've got
another wave of things you've got to
think about and it was great and I'm
really hoping that we can capture that
spirit of that and give it to gamers
today because you know I think it's
beautiful when a game is constructed and
feels really know in style all the way
through but that doesn't mean they all
have to be gray or they all have to be
brown because that's very you know sort
of classic gaming color schemes right
now aha I'm so you know I can say we
wait some of our levels get really quite
psychedelic you know I mean like one
level has pink trees for example and you
know another level has you know green
underground bases and
it's all kind of a bit weird and in the
original it was very sort of alien and
you know you had technology alongside
magic and that's something else that we
want to do I mean you in the middle of
the original you got a gun and a jetpack
so you know you can obviously I'm really
passionate about the original game so
hopefully we can make sure that this one
has a similar set of what on earth is
going to happen next really yeah that
would be great if it even one player
gets back yeah it is a delightful sort
of feeling to be surprised by a game and
not just sort of you know the kind of
surprised where you see the trailer and
it's kind of game you hadn't imagined
before that's doing something new in a
way that you had envisioned but to
actually be playing a game have a
conception of sort of what kind of game
you're in for and then to be surprised
with in the game yeah that's something
that yeah it doesn't necessarily happen
too often yeah also I mean 25 years of
gaming between that and now and I want
to make sure that the things that made
that feel unique but with all of the
amazing things that I've experienced
since and all the games that I made
sense and learnt from I want to make
sure that well hopefully this one can
you know I mean the team is so super
passionate about trying all these
different ideas and sonu been massively
supportive letting us go and do that you
know I mean I think a lot of credit goes
to them for letting us let me just try
this at all because such it's kind of a
mad thing to describe and you know the
fact that they're happy to let us try it
has just been fantastic I can't believe
I've got this opportunity so well take
some credit for yourself to Matt the
game is shaping up really wonderfully do
you guys have a release date in mind
well I mean that you can share with me
at this point um what would we were or a
window where I mean as a team we're
trying really hard and again sony been
so supportive we we have spent a lot of
time we're finally happy with this level
we know what we want to build for all
the others and when we're happy with
them we'll let you get out but you know
hopefully will be it will be within a
year and you know people will be able to
play it hopefully shadow the Beast matt
burch thank you so much for coming on
and I go in my office really appreciate
you you're doing great at your first III
and I hope you get some time to walk
around and check that I looking forward
to seeing the last guardian oh yeah
that's going to be good all right ladies
and gentlemen will be back here on
gamespot stage at e3 2015 in just a
moment but first a check in on
Assassin's Creed syndicate brought to
you by msi